Một kemp tinh nó như ở trường hấp tài khu bột điều đó xây rài
nên các bạn chỉ cần trón em một điểm trời đây
thì nó cũng tương tưởng tưởng cái một điểm trời này
Tại vì nó tinh trất đôi xin
Trời ơi mà nếu trực vui sướng của cảnh hình bẹ này luôn
nên kemp tìm đỉnh đ volume đẩy bây đểu gì đó thì đủ thôi
Tụi là bà trên đời kemp khu cần đi xem điểm cho nó bây giờ kìm xotion
điểm cho nó bây nó nó sẽ có điểm đôi xin nó ссыл nhau
nên vui sướng nó giống nhau
nên là gát xin, làm thị nhau
Bà i vào nhau
Chỉ là thứ A, bỏ ngon biểu năm 2019,
EAVC sẽ được hai cái,
cho ai chính ngon,
nhưng như thế bài toàn là chảy đến ngon,
công cạnh.
Nen chủ vô mục lý của thế bài nè.
Dạc em bị quá sợ để tình chất đôi sử.